claude blanchemaison bonjour bonjour
heureux de vous retrouver ce matin sur
rtl france alors on le disait en vue des
offensives des talibans les américains
pensent ralentir le rythme du retrait de
leurs troupes
alors que les pourparlers sont au point
mort pourquoi finalement le dialogue
pour la paix entre talibans et
gouvernement semble impossible
je crois d'abord tout simplement parce
que les talibans ne veulent pas négocier
réellement avec le gouvernement de
kaboul
tant que les troupes américaines ne sont
pas partis l accord a été passé entre
les talibans et les etats unis c'est que
les talibans ne tirera pas sur les
troupes américaines en train de se
retirer
le retrait devait avoir lieu en mars
maintenant il a lieu le 11 septembre
dans sa fait 20ans l'anniversaire
naturellement des attentats les twin
towers date éminemment symbolique mais
en réalité dans cette négociation avec
les talibans
les américains se sont mis en situation
d'infériorité à partir du moment où ils
ont dit qu'ils avaient décidé de leur
retrait s'ils avaient dit nous nous
retirons si vous négocier un accord de
paix avec kaboul
les choses auraient été différentes ils
ont d'abord négocié leur retrait avec
les talibans qui sont donc engagés à ne
pas compliquer ce retrait et à ne pas
s'attaquer aux troupes américaines en
cours de retrait mais évidemment ils ne
sont pas engagés à grand chose
le vis-à-vis du gouvernement de kaboul
et il pense que le temps travaille pour
eux que le rapport de force se modifie
en leur faveur ils sont très bien
implantés dans les campagnes ils sont
très proches d'un certain nombre de
villes ou un douzaine semble-t-il qui
pourrait tomber dès qu'ils le d2
déciderait et ils ont en effet repris
l'offensive
le principe de printemps c'est la
situation qui prévaut sur le terrain et
on comprend bien que monsieur rani va à
washington pour chercher un appui mais
cet appui ne modifiera pas sensiblement
la situation il faut sans doute décider
qui défendra l'aéroport de kaboul qui
est un délit
évidemment tout à fait stratégique la
ville de kaboul elle-même aussi alors
bien sûr il ya les troupes que les
américains vont former les troupes
afghanes dont ses troupes afghanes ont
dit que 1/4 sombre véritablement bien
formés c'est la partie troupes spéciales
quand les faits sont sans doute capable
de défendre la capitale pendant un
certain temps mais ça ne sera pas le cas
pour d'autres villes
et on dit déjà que certains alliés les
américains
les turcs sont bien entendu volontaires
pourraient rester pour défendre
l'aéroport de kaboul
ce qui évidemment ne sera pas acceptable
pour les talibans qui continueront de
refuser un partage du pouvoir avec le
gouvernement actuel
tant que les troupes étrangères seront
sur le sol afghan
alors ce week-end dans un communiqué les
talibans ont appelé la communauté à
laisser les afghans à laisser les avons
décidé de leur sort de celui de leur
pays
la communauté internationale est ce
qu'elle craint de voir les talibans
revenir au pouvoir et imposer le même
régime finalement qu entre 1996 et 2001
alors les talibans font filtrer que
naturellement ils ont échangé en vingt
ans la situation a évolué et qu'il ya
aussi un rajeunissement dans leur cadre
et que sur certains aspects ils ont
changé mais comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure ils veulent imposer un régime
islamique
total et on voit bien que dans les zones
qu'ils contrôlent d'ores et déjà ils ont
rétabli la charia cela veut dire que les
jeunes filles ne vont plus à l'école
elle reste chez elle cela veut dire que
les femmes ne peuvent plus sortir de
chez elle sans être accompagnée par un
homme cela veut dire que en effet c'est
un changement de régime alors ils auront
sans doute du mal à aboutir à ce
résultat dans les plus grandes villes et
notamment à kaboul où la population vit
de manière totalement différente mais il
est probable que cela prendra du temps
mais c'est leur objectif leur objectif
est de rétablir la charia et avec tout
ce que en effet la communauté la
communauté mondiale et data mans
naturellement les occidentaux n'accepte
pas simplement il on peut dire beaucoup
de difficultés à empêcher ce retour de
la charia et notamment en ce qui
concerne le sort des femmes en ce qui
concerne l'éducation en ce qui concerne
les éléments les plus visibles de la vie
sociale alors le président américain joe
biden a fixé la date symbolique du 11
septembre pour le retrait des troupes
américaines ça ne devrait pas changer
c'est ce qui a été annoncé hier soir
qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir de cette
présence américaine 20 ans et rennes ont
donc il s'est passé beaucoup de choses
durant ces vingt années et il ya eu la
date du helmand à fait symbolique au
bout de dix ans de la de lacq delà de la
capture enfin de la 2de de ben laden et
les options des troupes spéciales
américaines ayant retrouvé le lieu où il
se cachait étant parvenu à le tuer ça a
sûrement été à un point très important
puisque l'opération américaine et avec
avec les alliés des américains avaient
été déclenchées à la suite de l'attentât
du 11 septembre
mais évidemment le l'afghanistan est un
pays très particulier très singulier à
tel point que le gouvernement actuel de
kaboul a réuni il ya deux ans ce qu'on
appelle la loya jirga c'est à dire une
assemblée d'environ 2000 notables qui
sont les anciens les barbes blanches qui
ont bondi en afghanistan plus un certain
nombre de représentants de la société
civile pour renforcer sa position et la
loya jirga est le type même d'assemblée
traditionnelle dans un pays tels que
l'afghanistan avec des responsables
locaux qui ont beaucoup d'autonomie avec
des responsables locaux qui sont bien
souvent d'anciens chefs de guerre
d'anciens seigneurs de la guerre et qui
il faut bien le dire aussi vive bien
souvent de la culture du pavot et par
conséquent d
la vente d'un certain nombre de produits
stupéfiants
c'est d'ailleurs l'une des promesses des
talibans qui en lorsqu'il était parvenu
au pouvoir la première fois avait
indiqué la culture du pavot est probable
que bien que cela heurtera les chefs
locaux qui vivent de cette économie est
bien il est probable qu'ils
entreprendront aussi cette fois-ci
l'éradication de cette culture
donc la situation et est très difficile
parce qu'on a là une société qui a une
constitution de type occidental mais qui
n'est pas du tout organisé à
l'occidentale et qui vit encore suivant
d'autres logiques
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison on
vous retrouve mardi prochain pour un
nouvel édito diplôme en attendant on
peut vous répondre sur les réseaux
sociaux